I watched those
uh I was watching One on uh 2020 the
other day dude I'm old now because I'm
like watching 2020 and [__] I used to
get so mad at my mom I is it on TV still
yeah dude it's on TV I they're in season
45 at least do you watch TV oh I watch
like a little Netflix every now and then
or HBO or something like that no I love
TV TV like with commercials I want to
watch a
commercial
you're so crazy I'm like a Nostalgia guy
bro I'm like really you remember there
was a time whenever we could not fast
forward the commercial I remember at all
I I remember I got a to you remember to
yes I do and you could pause TV this is
crazy you could pause your TV and then
they started implementing it into Direct
TV we can just pause the feed this is
incredible go to the kitchen pause take
a leak pause pause like unreal yeah you
don't have to run back in what happened
I want to watch a commercial and
commercials work on me too like
seriously bro I'm like the guy that like
buy [__] off of commercials uh I'm like
yo I got to see this because I'm like oh
my God this is real but I'm watching
2020 on on TV because I want to like
watch I for Fast Forward some but I
watched one called The Dating Game
Killer bro The Dating Game Killer I
heard about this one dude was a serial
killer back in the 70s and he was on The
Dating Game he was on how that's a bad
person knowing he's got that many bodies
out there and he's on National
Television how many people had he killed
before he got on the bro he killed a
number he killed a woman way back dude
could you like growing up back like
being an adult in the 60s and 70s nuts
there is no internet there is no cell
phones women that were out there in the
world were at risk for serial killers
because you couldn't track them this
woman and her husband our boyfriend had
went up to like Montana the boyfriend
got mad at her left her just left her
this guy picks her up kills her they
don't find her till like 2000 and she
was when they found her they found that
she was pregnant at the time he killed
her and he killed a number of other ones
and then he went on The Dating Game Show
he was a bad guy and then you can find
that video bro the guy on The Dating
Game The Dating Game Killer is what he
was called I remember he looked real he
looked scary too didn't he and then bro
he they caught look at him look at him
they caught him because he was trying to
take a little girl from a
school Hey Joe and when they caught that
when they finally got this dude at the
end Joe they met him in jail cuz he had
been rotten in jail for years look at
all these women he got look at all these
women he got God he was just a bad guy
can Jamie can you go back to him talking
can I hear him talking this is the
Inside Edition report yeah can you see
if I look really
good she
pick is actually a serial killer I'm
called the banana and I look really
good no one had any idea about it Joe
imagine people were laughing at that
back then can you believe that I'm
called the banana I'm called the banana
like some of the [__] on TV was crazy
really good hey man everyone's
like he said the banana that gal was
going to get killed by this guy oh my
God but she when they set them up on the
date she goes he's very creepy I don't
like him they said when they went to see
this dude and he's on his like he's
dying in jail and they start bringing up
these women that they had found they
said it was almost like he was going to
a place of
euphoria cuz even though he was like on
his death bed and he couldn't move he
was thinking back to those times that's
a bad guy oh my God he was like he's
like on the thing
like like like literally like losing his
mind oh my God because he's thinking of
killing this woman or like doing what he
was doing to these ladies it's nuts bro
that's a bad guy they let
him uh act as his own attorney in his
third trial and he self- examined
himself for four four or five hours oh
my God yeah dude
2020 I'm telling you you're allowed to
do that I mean they probably that's this
might be one of the last times I don't
know are you allowed to do like whatever
you want you're if you're [__] out of
your own attorney and you're out of your
mind what you're going to be your own
attorney you dumb [__] I remember there
was a guy that uh killed a bunch of
people on the subway in Long Island and
then he acted as his own attorney too
they lose every time and so he was
questioning the witnesses he's like
[__] you shot me [__] you talking about
you [__] shot
me you're lying yeah the defendant says
that oh my God what you saying the
defendant that's you [__] you [__]
shot
me but that's just somebody that's
really messed up yeah crazy crazy people
but they're like formed they're not born
like that no I mean um at least I don't
think so who knows what they're born
like there is problems people do have
mental illness that runs in families
yeah they do that's real man I know
people that have it it's it's weird it's
very weird it's weird because it's like
if you don't have it and then you see
other people that do have it you go whoa
what is that like like what is
schizophrenia like yeah there's you know
I know people that are out there really
out there I I've never met anybody with
like with that I know people that come
back and they start acting normal again
then they go out there again and you
never know which one you're going to get
when you talk to them that's not good
yeah not good or manic when a person's
manic that's when they're really uh
strugg yeah this is the guy my the one
thing I noticed was I could hear shots
being fired already Solomon Butler is
that man accused of shooting at Clement
defending Butler posed question I don't
think this is the one wait did you see
that guy's head did that guy get shot in
the head oh my God he
did no in court the injury to Butler's
head was obvious officer Clemens wow wow
I've never seen anything like that he's
missing a chunk of his head I've never
seen anything like that I've seen a few
things like that really yeah people
survive gunshot wounds and half their
head's missing half of the head's
missing yeah and they can still function
somewhat people can live like in a lot
of different circumstances where a lot
of stuff's missing mhm it's crazy that
they're still alive that's crazy that
was nuts his whole inside of his head's
like dented in so where's his brain that
part's probably not there anymore of the
that part of his brain yeah is gone is
gone yeah so I guess the rest of the
brain has to pick up the slack or
something wow part of your body doesn't
work well that's so crazy oh yeah that's
a freaky looking image there yeah this
was a different one but it doesn't
matter Jamie that's fine um it was a
Subway killer in Long
Island yeah man serial killer there's a
lot of [__] up dudes out there women
love serial killer shows why dude weird
right it's so weird cuz they but can a
serial killer exist today yes you think
so yeah they exist no there's active
there's active serial killers yeah how
with all the stuff like with the DNA and
the the videos and the cameras and the
phones and the tracking well you have to
have people looking for you first of all
right so you have to have left some sort
of evidence to begin
with